so actinium it's often said about
radioactivity that you might be glowing
in the dark if you work with radioactive
elements by and large it's not true
however actinium is one of them which
might do that because the element itself
glows blue in the dark are actinium is
actually more dangerous than plutonium
and plutonium was once described as the
most deadly and toxic substance known to
man so it's pretty dangerous have you
got anything to do with at all no
because it's so dangerous when I was an
undergraduate I saw this book here which
was written by Seaborg and I really like
the cover because I think it looked
really nice and I was also quite
interested about the transuranium
elements because I didn't really know
much about them and he probably more
than anybody else discovered more of
these elements than any than any other
scientists probably more elements than
most if not all scientists and he wrote
in this book about the chemistry of the
different elements and although we
consider that these are pretty
radioactive and so on they at least
managed to isolate enough material so
you could see it at the bottom of a
small glass tube it may not have been
any bigger than the tip of a pin or
something like that but it's a huge
amount compared to the one or two atoms
that were formed of some of these
elements and very near the end of the
periodic table